what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Sathyan super pumped
to be talking about techno fascism and
Big Pharma we have miriam canaan joining
us on the show
hi Miriam hello thank you so much for
coming in on the program really
appreciate it and I'm making an
exception because I gave up handshaking
in 2009 only hugs
I would only hug - not everybody don't
hug everybody and nobody not everybody
wants ugh me believe it or not thanks
for making room for the exception we
appreciate it love it thank you for
those that don't know Miriam's
background she is an investigative
journalist functional medicine
consultant and founder and
editor-in-chief of honey colony she is
also the director of the award-winning
document documentary film vanishing of
the bees narrated by Ellen Page and is
now exposing techno fascism censoring
free speech biasing search results in
the sick ties between Big Pharma and big
tech and you find all of her links in
the bio below to her Twitter profile the
piece and the epoch times on her as well
as honey colony comm thank you
oh my gosh there's so much to talk about
I know I'm so excited for this so let's
start things off by talking to you about
this you know this big-picture
perspective you know we find ourselves
here embedded in this creation
simulation why are we here what is the
purpose of this a reality such a big
question to unpack I would like to say
that we are from my perspective
spiritual beings in these meet bodies
having so spiritual beings having this
experience on this third dimension and
for me personally having almost died
that I want to make this life count and
I feel that it's about reaching your
potential identifying patterns knowing
thyself and
we're living specifically right now and
pretty crazy times exciting times where
there's an acceleration that's happening
a quickening and there's seemingly
mayhem and let's see where where the
rides leads us yeah spiritual beings
having a human experience here and that
we may be a part of the coming aliveness
of creation feeling more interconnected
with the more belonging and yet there's
this this weird like where are we going
feeling that's among us right now
the title of the episode about techno
fascism in Big Pharma
what are these forces that are at play
that are coming into you know make this
a you know make this challenging that
that the planetary evolution is based on
these challenges and not based on oh
you're just born into a utopia enjoy and
I think that technology and maybe social
media has given us a perspective or has
shown us the disparity let's say between
mainstream media and what's really
happening like Marshall McLuhan talked
about a global village when I was in New
Journalism school and we're seeing this
global village and you can also argue
although it sounds negative a kid and I
say that the future is here the zombies
are now because there's a dumbing down
of society and we're amazing creatures
and and let's say even like having
reversed an autoimmune condition and
being told your body's attacking itself
what a damaging thought that is when 96%
of us were run by our subconscious and
so going from Wow thinking my body is
attacking itself to going to we're
amazing and we have not reached our
potential technology has helped us in
all our ways but there's inner
technology that we have
Talton to Bernard talks about that who's
gonna get guests on your show
Bernard Gunter yeah so looking looking
inside and the technology right now and
social media is having an impact on
society in ways that we're just
beginning to see right this whole
obsession these selfies like kill fees
have you heard of kill fees the house
has so outside magazine did a episode of
all people who have died during taking
selfies because they've gone on
treacherous or they've gone like climbed
mountains and then they end up dying in
pursuit of that selfie yeah or videos
there's also once that go and jump from
those really big they're like you know
hundred stories outside and then we jump
from the ledges and then some people die
doing that for these videos I don't know
if it's the same one I've seen that
video that one particular video of
jumping like I don't know 15 times
thinking like wow doing like a backflip
all different types of stuff I have a I
have a question about this this know
thyself in this so in the process of
coming aliveness you you bring it up and
it's so important that when we come
through for this adventure as a
spiritual being coming into the human
body that there is this deep calling for
us to understand why we are here and
what is our unique gift that we're
bringing to the world how have you
yourself figured that out about yourself
and what are some of the core principles
that maybe other people can well I'd
like to say that purpose having studied
Blue Zones and longevity and why and
those are like there's five areas in the
world where people live eighties 90s a
hundred that person's like Okinawa
Okinawa Nicoya in Costa Rica seven
Adventists in California sardinia
acharya in greece and these in reality
these places are becoming extinct but
the point is that purpose is it's very
important there's a japanese words that
xscape smiie right now that embodies per
so I feel blessed that I have a purpose
that came along after a literal
near-death experience because I see
people that are kind of flowing floating
aimlessly like a dandelion seed not
knowing what what they're meant to do so
in my case I think it became clearer
after almost dying and and also
embracing during my near-death
experience the the philosophy of know
thyself which I stumbled upon when I was
in Greece at Delphi at the Oracle of
Delphi and saw it in in Greek know
thyself where the be goddess is
ironically word and just was real like
kind of a confirmation and I think that
as we're navigating through this third
dimension that it would be lovely if
more people took self accountability to
be able to because there's so much
projection going on right now
mm-hmm and we are mirrors and I feel
that different spirits activate each
other in different ways like could bring
out different aspects because we're like
diamonds hopefully mm-hmm I'm
multifaceted
mm-hmm so it's really difficult in this
matrix to find a purpose when people are
forced to take a job or put food on the
table and now more than ever the
pressures of the economic machinery yeah
and if now more than ever you know I
have like I take an informal poll asking
people do you know that Google is is
manipulating search results do you know
that there's like no more organic search
results or they're using mind control
tactics and it's interesting because
people sometimes consciously well don't
care because like just the other day I
asked someone and he's like yeah but
there's still the best search engine
then I had another conversation with
someone who consciously said I choose
convenience over privacy because data
today is the most precious asset
in the world and we are arguably numbers
so but it's important to have a passion
and to wake up we're being asked to wake
up this is an opportunity to wake up
yeah and there's different levels of
waking up right yeah yeah it's almost as
though the spirit is coming through for
the human experience and going through a
process of conscious evolution and
there's different stages for every
single person that everyone's at right
now
and the idea of becoming an enlightened
being to the truth is something that is
extremely beautiful and it's extremely
important to prioritize and we're not
taught that in schools what so ever to
become light and being and and to go
through that process nor by our parents
usually to know thyself and to find your
own unique gifts to bring to the world
and to know you're actually
interconnected with all other things
they're not a separate yeah I mean in
regards to like I had studied psychic
skills and they tell you do you really
want to be connected with everybody
because people are just like oh we're
all one but at the same time to hold
space especially today like I'm not able
to really relate with the matrix
necessarily and want to embody myself
not in a arrogant or selfish selfish way
but also understand that the other
person is a reflection of you you know
so if someone's triggering you to take
responsibility because nothing happens
in a vacuum and so also I think like
there's so much emphasis on the brain
and not recognizing the resonance of the
heart is stronger than the brain so that
is that component is lost when you we
see social media and we see the vitriol
and right now you know I observe a virus
of hate
that's happening yeah and that's one of
the reasons personally that I've been a
little bit disenchanted with Democrats
or liberals or whatever left-leaning
label you you want to put because
they're espousing lots of hatred as is
the far-right both in the US and just in
general around the world extremists have
been for a long time doing exactly
exactly that when there's a nuance and
there's beautifulest potential ascension
that can happen between us by finding
the nuance and by falling in love with
what is the complexity of these
conversations in the non binary thinking
around it one and well I want to
endeavor into this with you you know you
ended up figuring out more about
yourself and more about this reality and
then the vanishing of the bees happened
and I'm very curious what was this
calling of creation through you that
made you want to make this well it was
really getting hit by a Ford Explorer
and being dragged 50 feet across the
cement and being so fortunate I did have
to learn how to walk again but the car
didn't roll over my brain and she's went
what year was this so this was in 2003 I
was 29 s was during my Saturn return and
they might God just like actually later
when I had an astrologer do a reading
was like right on like the money and I
was in front of the Bodhi tree which is
a now-defunct metaphysical bookstore on
Melrose Avenue and ironically let I had
my spiritual awakening when I was 13 and
it was in part by reading out on a limb
being raised coptic christian and going
to church and then starting to question
things that didn't jive and reading out
on a limb where she references the bodhi
tree and then fast-forward all these
years I had actually gone with my
boyfriend at the time
my two very close friends to Joshua Tree
and we saw a coyote and for whatever
reason it was a baby coyote I was kind
of mesmerized by this coyote and I went
that day to the Bodhi tree to look up
the meaning of coyote who's the
trickster in folklore and wrote the
meaning down close my journal didn't
really take it in just kind of
transcribed it and then ended up getting
hit by this SUV and dragged 50 feet and
that was really kind of an initiation
towards where I am today being a
functional medicine consultant and I Wow
it acted as your initiation yeah that
you saw immediately the treasure on the
other side of this detail traumatic
experience immediately but it but it's
cute cool that now you know 16 years
jeez later but that seeing it like that
this is this is a big hopefully yeah
it's a huge theme on the show happens
all the time it's so hard to see it
initially as a treasure yeah but that it
is a treasure that even on a planetary
scale that we went through such hell in
so many ways because we're gonna really
learn love that way I hope so yeah and
so you learned functional medicine from
well there's so many things because I
had to heal myself and I quickly learned
Oh
Western medicine I mean I from Canada
had been here in America I think at that
time less than four years or so and then
quickly had to kind of take health into
my own hands because they didn't even
give me physiotherapy because I didn't
have insurance and in fact imagine
getting hit by a car at 30 miles an hour
opening your eyes and the someone comes
to your aid and the first thing that I
said was I don't have insurance to think
that way to be like oh [ __ ] I'm not
covered and what has exactly happened
I'm laying down on the on the cement and
I say to people it's not what happens to
you but what you do with what happens to
you and it certainly was
fun and I was not a pleasant person
because I was living in chronic pain and
my body kind of exploded it was only it
was not only the leg it was like an
ovarian cyst it was strep throat it was
PTSD and then that led me like on in a
very you know now gluten-free is common
but it was it common in 2005 no so just
completely and also my my super my
superpowers were heightened like I woke
up with super nasal powers and lights
would go off sometimes still doom the
whole my whole kind of frequency changed
my field something happened because
during a near-death experience I was
nowhere and everywhere at the same time
mm-hmm
that feeling right there Wow nowhere and
everywhere at the same time yeah yeah
knowing that there's something beyond
but just kind of becoming part of
everything but you're nothing in that
in-between state mm-hmm and then it was
a long a long trek to have a mission and
then you know I decided up until then I
was a freelance journalist I worked for
MSNBC and I quit that and then I was
pitching and writing for The Hollywood
Reporter for penthouse for detour and
then decided that I didn't I had this
kind of fascination with the seedy side
of Los Angeles as of wire of as someone
who was raised pretty in a conservative
not Muslim but Christian household
Egyptian and so I was kind of fascinated
I minored in psychology and so I would
look at these stories and kind of inject
myself kind of Hunter as Thompson style
and then I wanted to do something that
was greater than me something that I
could be in service and so one of the
first projects I worked with the Sierra
Club and Robert Greenwald
and help produce a piece on the Exxon
Valdez oil spill and another one on the
asbestos the injuries at 9/11 and then
George languidly who's the co-director
of vanishing of the bees and I decided
to collaborate and someone told him his
friend told him you know the bees are
disappearing all over the world and he's
into mysteries and I took an afternoon
doing research and found out it's a
sacred Society and the bees are all
about the greater good and our ancient
messengers and then I started having
literal be visitations what the bees are
part of a more time than I started
having literal be visitation be
visitations in their part one more time
the bees are of an ancient babies are
ancient messengers ancient messengers I
mean they're they're ancient they've
been symbolically they're known as as
messengers they teaches collaboration
they teaches community they teach us
selflessness they feed us they feed you
know they give us one in every three
bites of the food so other pollinators
are disappearing but I guess they're the
most valuable to us and the European
honeybee is not even its it's not native
to America I mean so there's other
native bees that are dying but because
they're the more most profitable they're
environmental indicators just you
talking about bees and the vanishing of
the bees makes me feel more
interconnected with everything that
exists here that it's that that that we
the police such a vital role in
everything that we experience and the
food that we eat and the way that we can
study them and their behaviors and the
way that we ourselves can potentially
behave more interconnected ly as well
can be very helpful to building a new
world let's say like you're passing by a
rose rosemary bush or a a patch of
flower
and you don't see the bees at first and
then if you kind of like I've done this
so many times just kind of Zone in and
then all of a sudden you see there's
like 10 bees yeah and they're doing
their business and nobody is really
paying attention so you kind of have to
slow down into that frequency to see
them and this is happening in the insect
world all around and we have lost that
respect or that reverence even between
each other in the way we communicate
meaning also like to be able to have a
conversation with someone that's not
necessarily in agreement with you we're
not supposed to be clones of one another
but this is how we learn and the system
now is about divide and conquer is about
dumbing people down not inspiring
critical thinking or metacognition which
is the thinking of thinking and that's
why I like long-form podcasts and watch
them or listen to someone like Jordan
Peterson who really knows how to parse
out something and take it in different
directions and explore it from a
psychological point of view and exchange
ideas that's how we learn and and also
making mistakes and reminding ourselves
that were human like where is the sense
of forgiveness where is the sense of
like instead you're just banning
Roseanne Barr you're banning Alex Jones
and these are serving as poster children
in what was coming which is techno
fascism mm-hmm well I really enjoy how
we kind of wandered into into it back
into it because to me it's so deeply
interconnected the way that we see what
you did with bees and trying to bring
that forth into our world so that people
can slow down and that they can look at
for longer times that maybe patches of
flower or tree and just look deeper and
they can see after a little bit of time
that when you go to like a rose garden
you go to a bunch of different flowers
eventually you do end up look going in
and you see Obie's already in there kind
of
going deep into the pollen and it's
beautiful to see that and then you also
see that again kind of with the way that
they're communicating and their
interconnectedness and this greater goal
of the Beehive and the honey and and how
we ourselves have so much
interconnectedness with them that we
need to respect and how that leads to us
and our interconnectedness and how when
you have a platforms that have been made
by thank you internet and and technology
that has helped catalyze these these
platforms that in order for us to
maximize our efficiency with being able
to consciously evolve together that we
need to figure out what is most optimal
this is not banning someone that is
murdering someone else on these
platforms this is banning people for
literally the things that they're saying
and this is not this is so important to
figure out what is most optimal to do
here and how yeah and how do you find
the nuance with it to like these
companies have a struggle with making
sure that's someone that's actually
killing someone or raping someone or
committing an act of violence does not
get the opportunity to have the platform
to do so where are their platforms or
they publishers they need to make their
minds and they can't decide Midway or
now our publishers if you don't like
something turn off turn the [ __ ]
channel you have the choice and this is
about taking away our sovereignty and so
it's the most important thing to me I
believe in freedom of speech and to be
taken away or then it's like a slippery
slope where I notice that say on our on
honey colony
I was trying I was pitching the story to
Marie Claire magazine about CBD Beach
that's when I first noticed techno
fascism in 2016 and pitching pitching
the editor and then having the main
stand wanting to penetrate the
mainstream again because kind of hard
now
to penetrate or can't relate to it so it
was very keen on having this story
published and having the editor call me
at home and ask me by my office what are
your personal views on vaccines that has
never happened in 25 years of being a
journalist where someone is asking me
about a completely different topic and
such a polarized polarizing topic in any
case I didn't get the story published
maybe I answered wrong but I brought it
up because we had a couple of stories on
vaccines on our site very well written
very well sourced and I found myself
asking my marketer if we can draft the
story before I was turned down so
engaged in an act of self-censorship and
even told my marketer I can't believe
that I'm doing this and I think that is
a slippery slope when you start you know
just being policing yourself and when I
was writing about techno fascism I got
an intuitive hit to read 1984 and pulled
a lot of quotes and it was it really
made it was chilling because there were
vaporizing words or rewriting history
google is burying information and I saw
things in real time disappearing from
the internet and as a researcher
journalists the experience is not the
same so now I use a lot of different
search engines and do a comparison of
what comes up and a lot of the
information is is buried a lot of the
information has been rewritten Wikipedia
is like you know Google sidekick and
it's constituted two new levels you
could argue that censorship or that fake
news is old news we used to have yellow
journalism but the difference is like
Mike's turn orig was an independent
journalist and author filmmaker says
that like what I said earlier that it's
really social media that shows us the
disparity of what's being covered and
what's really happening and now we have
these like multiple narratives happening
at the same time that are completely
different specifically to confuse people
that they don't know what the hell is
truth yeah I want to ask you about that
actually there's so many other things
that you listed I wanna talk about but
let's let's unpack where we just were
why the confusion what is behind the
confusion why is it not so clear that we
want more content around our deep
interconnectedness and are coming
aliveness and our unique gifts to bring
to the world abundance love why is that
buried compared to fear what what's
propagating scarcity and trauma and fear
well that's a really good question that
I don't necessarily have all the answers
to believing in the elite or with the
loominatee or the Cabal or whatever you
want to put a name to it the families
that run things that that there's
overpopulation and having studied the
food supply and food politics and
nutrition and chronic disease or one in
every two people today is chronically
ill that there's arguably a depopulation
agenda
there's definitely control and this
divide and conquer strategy is working
and that's part of the strategy when you
start to unpack things and you realize
like who really created the United
Nations and what is the purpose and it's
just like Bayer CropScience which is
mentioned in my film that's responsible
for systemic pesticides they have a
b-wing month Satan Monsanto had a bee
wing so on one hand doing good or but in
reality and then there's a lot of good
people part of an organization that
don't really realize the bigger
machinations or the bigger picture right
so I use there
of let's say you're an actor and you get
cast in the commercial you just want to
do the best job you're just happy that
you landed the gig and you want to know
your lines but you're not really
necessarily a knowledge Anor you're
peddling drugs or you're part of a
bigger machine just even being a PA on a
commercial and seeing the [ __ ] loads of
money that they waste for you know a
stupid in name commercial so this has
been this is history in the making where
we've lost touch with our sacredness yes
yeah that's the big thing is losing
touch with our sacredness I love the way
you put that as though the spiritual
world and the physical world have yet to
have a really deep loving marriage
happen and that it's a it's up to us to
help catalyze that marriage that Union
to happen even more the way that it's
sacredly meant to happen this is the
exact process that we're supposed to be
going through of Awakening and conscious
evolution and you gave these examples
actually throughout I want to I want to
list them you give this example of life
when you have something that has 20
years of incumbency power of of
organizing the world's knowledge Google
in this case and then yeah and then you
have these different experiments where
you have China and China's relationship
with Baidu their government and their
relationship with their people and
private companies the way they control
their people and surveil surveil and
what in what is you know that's their
own experiment and there's its own
experiment happening in the USA and
there's different experiments happening
in different countries with governments
technologies censorship sat set free
speeches etc and so when you do
something like try and organize
society's knowledge and then have people
query it to understand the world that
they're in if you're swaying people in a
very
specific direction when they're doing
that this is already a tremendous thing
that needs to be studied and D more
deeply understood because we're querying
the world's knowledge yeah I think we
also all speak for myself took it for
granted that the internet like I've been
part of the Internet as a journalist
from from the get-go and feel very
fortunate like at MSNBC in the late 90s
producing the news for the Internet when
they just introduced the website you
know so-so thinking that this is a
benevolent a benevolent space cyberspace
and then techno fascism is this over
reliance on computer mediated
information so we've taken it for
granted before we know it Google is the
biggest search engine on the planet
before we know it Google is also a drug
company before we knew it there
literally using mind control tactics and
to try to say that that's a conspiracy
when you have someone like Zak dump nine
hundred and fifty pages and confirm a
lot of the things that we've been
experiencing in the health world I'm
specifically I mean it's all areas but
I'm specifically focusing on health
freedom and where the what are we
without our health someone who's almost
died who's had a chronic also reverse
lupus and fibromyalgia and very familiar
with chronic illness like you you can't
it becomes a full-time job and it's the
most important thing and the fact that
they're burying information to empower
you and then they're they're propagating
let's say the natural fallacy which is
like not everything in nature is safe
for you sure it's a dog-eat-dog world if
you look at and if you look at nature
just if you look at the bees I mean at
the end of the summer they kick the the
worker bees it's ninety percent female
they kick the drones out if they haven't
made it with the Queen and if they have
made you with the Queen then their
phallus pops off and they tumble to the
death so I'm not saying that as a dig
towards men at all but I'm just saying
if you look at nature it's it's not kind
necessarily survival of the fittest the
point is here is that these big tech
companies and you know I've been
focusing on Google because I've
personally 76 percent of my traffic has
plummeted because of their medic update
and they're unfair algorithmic changes
but I certainly can speak about a lot of
big tech companies whether it's Facebook
or before you know it like you said
there is deeper amount of ownership of
the substrate this is something we've
talked about on the show a lot is that
before you know it it's not just the
search engine that you go and query but
it's literally the the ownership of the
virtual worlds that you go and immerse
yourself into and all these other things
like you listed the involvement in
health care and and also like you you
know there's some this importance of
well maybe I want to have a deeper
relationship with my farmer and a deeper
relationship with the food that I go and
get and I don't just want it randomly
delivered to me by a drone or maybe that
is the convenience that somebody wants
but mountain but how can that literally
that is a one button click delivery also
be something that's completely trusted
that hasn't been completely manipulated
but that is a beautiful product of the
earth and not that also cook that goes
back to accountability to having a sense
of spirit to not be led by greed to be
human and this sense of control is
certainly nothing new I mean they burned
down the Library of Alexandria this is a
different iteration where it's happening
online but again now we see the
disparity so as a journalist seeing you
know oh you compare the silver burning
of the Library of Alexandria that's
interesting techno fascism is like who
what gets placed in the library and
where it goes
well there's purging of information and
let's say a lot of Health sites now if
you're using Google if you don't put
Mercola com self hack com green med
infocomm honey colony comm like maybe
you would know him or Cola but if
there's a lot of people that don't even
know about Mercola and he's a reputable
actual physician that predates Google so
if you don't know about the site the
information is not going to come up so
it's being buried and other information
you know there's a movement called bit
burning so instead of book burning oh
it's burned it bit burning yeah yeah
that that way of explaining it is a good
way bit burning yeah so it's not new
this control is not new it's that it has
to be suppressed more than ever today
because the truth has come out and
people have are starting to connect the
dots so it's not only conservatives that
are getting banned like why would
someone like a do-gooder an activist be
banned for life from PayPal or be
scrubbed off of GoFundMe so I'd been
scrubbed off of GoFundMe and just
learned that accel partners invested six
hundred million in acquiring them and
that they have investments in
pharmaceuticals they also have
investments in Spotify in slack in
DocuSign in all these different tech
companies in Facebook and these are all
different tech companies where exchange
of consumerism money or data like
DocuSign like if you have dibs on all
these things and then you know MailChimp
many people who had MailChimp imagine
waking up and you're a list that you've
been cultivating your email list is
deleted and gone because you're trying
to share information about vaccine
safety not to call them anti-vaxxers
these most of these people have children
who have endured injuries
why is there four billion dollars that
has been given to vaccine injured kids
because these pharmaceuticals have
impunity immunity and you can't go after
them they can't be held accountable so
this seems very reasonable for me to
have something like a like a vaccine
safety or like oh just a food safety or
whatever an Internet critical thinking
safety you don't want to be manipulated
and so what you do is you you just make
sure like hey like ask about what you're
eating or what you're you know popping
into your children's bodies and just be
very vigilant about it but now they're
taking those rights away if you look at
California then they took out religious
or personal beliefs then they removed
medical and exemptions now they're going
after the doctors to penalize the
doctors that they can give more than I
don't know five or they'll threaten
their license and then during the
research of techno fascism because I was
experiencing all these things
specifically at first with CBD and then
with Google and our traffic and then
realizing others like dr. Mercola
and then took a deep dive and learned
that Google has invested in a company
called foxy tech which is out of Oxford
which is developing a one-size-fits-all
flu vaccine that they're dubbing the
Holy Grail but that others think is a
nightmare
because it doesn't acknowledge
biodiversity you know you have a
different Constitution than I do
and then you realize that's when it hit
me I'm like oh that's why it's become so
polarized today to talk about vaccines
it's because one it's the decade of
vaccines I didn't know that - there's
all these vaccines in the pipeline the
schedule today is vastly greater than
when I was growing up in the
late seventies and then our indigenous
people vaccinating their children you
know what I mean like so always that
these types of look what did we do prior
to that and yeah chicken pox parties we
had something called our immune system
and then you learn that the [ __ ] that
they put in the vaccines
what's whether it's Nagle YZ or the fact
that you need a substrate to grow the
viruses and so they use fetal tissue so
they're injecting fetal tissue into the
body this is like sci-fi crazy sounding
and then they put formaldehyde and so
then you having studied again the food
supply water of interviewed Erin
Brokovich looking at the quality of the
soil how can you not conclude that we
are the bees that are slowly being
poisoned by a sub-lethal doses
slowly slowly so you can't point the
finger and say that's what that's what
killed you or that's what got you sing
and then not not realizing that the
different chemicals synergized it's a
combination of that and then the trauma
that's happening from the food system
and the trauma from the media system and
all of these other poisons are consuming
can be in a form of misinformation
disinformation fake news just - so as a
journalist also seeing and was part of
it in a way of like this angst
towards this one man Trump right and not
to question like yeah he's a narcissist
he doesn't have the best vocabulary is
not necessarily dignified but to have
all this hatred toward him when you
realize like this is supposed to be
democracy you lost the election so wait
it out and be good sports but instead
whether it's CNN or Google may have
occurred in 2016 and then before you
know it you're controlling people's
minds under the guise of safety under
the guise of we don't want the elections
to be rigged which is [ __ ]
let the people decide so you know Google
having it slow it's it's and just the
savior's knew there's nuance around this
point that's not theirs that's so
important to make clear like that you
you just look at where we come from and
our evolutionary trajectory to get here
who were we when we were first
discovering this like immediate return
hunter-gatherer civilization when we
were first moving up into from tribal
into the agrarian days and what what
what what shifts happened at that time
what shifts with our health happened at
our time revolution the Industrial
Revolution what shift happened at the
Industrial Revolution
what shifts happening right now with the
exponential technology age these are all
very important time periods to look at
what changes were happening in my health
what changes are happening in
misinformation what changes are
happening in the food system right these
big big areas that we live our lives so
dearly in like if I believe that you are
here as an inclusive stakeholder in my
life that you care about what food I eat
what health I have and my unique gifts
bringing those into the world then
there's not a chance that you're gonna
self deal you're not going to tell me a
lie
so that you can go up and I and I and I
die but this is a it's a really deep
first principle understanding of what we
had in our tribal days was a deeper
inclusive stake holding system for
inclusive fitness and now it seems like
we have top-down forces of potential
misinformation of over-over
pharmaceutical alized
over fed with foods that are just
causing people to feel sick less sleep
all these things less family more work
that's connected with nature just my
conclusion or my downloads is like we've
become disconnected with nature and you
can trace back like in my piece I talk
about the Flexner report which
started in 1910 basically when JP Morgan
and Carnegie and the Rockefellers
changed with the help of Abraham Flexner
changed the way in which we deal with
medicine to focus on patents and what I
call this full faith of science where
the science is maligned the science is
myopic and let's say the EPA doesn't do
any the Environmental Protection Agency
doesn't do any of its own independent
studies it's looking to bear to tell you
whether this systemic pesticide is safe
like what the [ __ ] that doesn't it's
like the fox guarding the hen house
right so there was this extra at the end
of the war there was these extra
chemicals these petrochemicals and these
have made their way into the food supply
and into the pharmaceuticals when you
find out all these shitty ingredients
that they sneaked in to the food supply
and someone will be like that you can't
pronounce that you can't pronounce so
you can't digest that's what I tell
people and that people are not really
looking at that the ingredients I was
having conversation with someone who's
like yeah I eat cereal in the morning
but there's all these these vitamins in
it I'm like dude those are all synthetic
vitamins they're not real and like let's
say fake folic acid can wreak havoc on
your methylation can wreak havoc on your
B levels and then you realize that let's
say let's define functional medicine for
a moment that's looking at you as an
individual so if you were my client
looking at all these nuances of like
even what was happening before you were
born yeah we're youwere you vaginally
born were you did you grow up on
antibiotics I really the stress levels
of your parents or what if they'd be
taking a whole timeline to get to the
root as opposed to managing symptoms in
what is called sick care and not to
throw out the baby with the bathwater
that I'm very fortunate that I had my
accident near cedars-sinai that they
were able to save my leg
that they're in emergency situations but
now they're trying to convince you that
just because a doctor just because it
has MD a guy has MD in four years they
have less than 25 hours of nutritional
education and indices all because of the
Flexner report where they close down a
lot of the universities that weren't
abiding by their kind of rules a lot of
the medical schools and then you had
this emphasis on giving drugs I want to
know does it seem like there's a bigger
agenda behind the pushing of these
disinformation these different tactics
and in in health and food that seem to
be moving people away from our
interconnectedness with nature and each
other and more towards in a sense just
shut up and be a part of the economic
machinery and what is behind that what
is behind that it seems like as I go
down that rabbit hole that there seems
to be dare I say it like satanic forces
maybe yeah
that that's even hard to say but I would
I would often say do these people bleed
red like are these people here but like
are merely human how can they I mean we
have an epidemic of let's say narcissism
now and of course there's a spectrum but
there's a lot of maligned narcissists
there's just a complete disconnect and
maybe that's something that wants to be
cultivated a disconnect to the spirit to
the heart I couldn't help but just think
about like people showing that they
bleed read about it show me if you a
little do a little cut on your hand
that yeah I'm real versus the robotic
future of EIU Hammond critical thinking
I think is at an all-time low and just
you know I encourage people to ask like
so why is it that I do the things that I
do whatever it is like why am I dressed
like this or why is it do I eat this way
to just really question and go inside
into the inner technology while the
outer technology has helped and it's
like you know I joke like if I could put
a chip in my brain to like increase my
brain cognitive skills as an
intellectual you know I would consider
that but doesn't mean I have to lose my
mind my spirituality mm-hmm so we see a
lot of kind of automatic behaviors that
that people don't even realize that
they're there's so there's so much more
that they can be what would you what
would you say for this coming aliveness
of each of us to ask that question why
am I doing this why am i doing that so
is it to get us more critical thinking
we need to be more reflective about
every single one of our like micro
behaviors that we do and just question
those and like who's telling me that you
know as if it's your mom you know you're
most likely being loved unconditionally
but if it's corporation the likelihood
that you're being loved unconditionally
oh [ __ ] so is that the critical thinking
is this mom or is this a corporation
that's trying to self deal for me to
just shut up and be a part of the
machinery and not teach me what is
really important well I don't know what
comes to mind is like ignorance is bliss
and it seems like when you're part of
the matrix like life is maybe easier or
look see the easier because people are
kind of bumbling along you know I I
don't know where it was at the grocery
store and just people who had casually
having calm
and I was kind of envious of the
simplicity the simplicity
meanwhile go back home and like what is
the nature of this reality trying to
take on Big Pharma yeah and I get the
truth out and being shadow band and like
so I say like some of us are blowing the
whistle but it's become a silent one I'm
putting in the info out hmm but but
Twitter's not allowing others to see it
so to go back to you gave MailChimp as
an example to give patreon spend at ease
an example all of these big tech
companies I've certainly felt the wrath
like waking up and like oh four years of
our ads or campaigns Facebook just took
it away just deleted it and then have to
bust out my press card have all these
merchant processors shut us down shut us
down shut us down I want to go back to
the to what you asked is it you said is
it it's mindfulness it's practicing
mindfulness it's it's a muscle mm-hmm
you know like what does that look like
yeah well I'm the fan of course in
miracles' it's self-awareness
it's meditating then catching yourself
it's it's it's being able to step away
and look at yourself and look at your
behaviors and it's not easy to break
behaviors and that's why there's health
coaches if you're talking about health
or friends but wanting to reach your
potential and not be controlled by other
external sources okay so we find
ourselves going on a trajectory of we're
born into the world I'm figuring out who
I am I'm figuring out what my unique
gifts are that I want to bring to the
world and then there's all these forces
that come in media government you know
parents or forces all different economic
machinery forces that are happening and
that then I'm discerning vigilantly
through my habits through how why are my
behaviors this way right and yes yes
Sudha incident ideas can you look at the
programming that's happening
can you see your own behaviors can you
ask your your closest friends and your
family and other people and just ask
them coaches can you ask them hey you
know I'm doing this
there's the give me give me give me some
information because you care about my
inclusive fitness so give me the truth
tell me what I should know that I may be
missing that's causing me to be less on
my path to this ultimate gift that I can
bring to the world am I just like you
said kind of like there's kind of like
digital a robot walking through well I
think for me my personal spiritual path
is a lot about deleting limiting beliefs
mmm-hmm through different modalities
different readings different but let's
say I look at not to dis my sister but
if I look at my sister and I work from
the same parents but we're completely
different in fact part of a lot of my
family has worked in the pharmaceutical
industry I don't see that my sisters on
a spiritual journey asking why or is
being able to say I'm sorry I [ __ ] up
I wish more people could just say that
yeah take some responsibility and
accountability ownership ownership and
realize maybe I projected maybe I was
like you know I lost my [ __ ] and to be
able to say I'm sorry
that's called adulting hello yeah that's
all hello is there is there anyone in
there that can knows how to say I'm
sorry yeah well it's true that most of
if and also forgiveness yeah
- just like vote someone off the island
today now we're shadow banning anyone
that's not peddling the status quo
anyone who's questioning that said
Jordan Peterson how maligned he's been I
a story I wrote a story on from a
functional medicine point of view why
Karn every worked for him and why it's
not for everyone and it was a very sound
well researched article and I had
mainstream editors one tell me
we're not gonna publish this because
we're scared of Twitter this is a
journalist or had another editor a
female say he's a white supremacist and
a misogynist to which I answered I'm a
brown woman have you read his book no
have you seen his videos no but you're a
reporter that's repeating you're just
repeating you're not really a reporter
you're not digging in and now there's so
much minutia you can keep you know the
layers of how deep can you go to really
be accurate and I know that when I edit
and I have my team editorial team it's
like they know that it's gonna go
through lots of edits because I'm a
stickler and I want to really source the
facts which is interesting because we
were led to believe that there was a
medic update there was several that
Google rolled out and that in order to
regain the rankings because in our case
we had 500,000 unique visitors a month
that's not a little that's a lot of
[ __ ] hard work yeah and those are
well researched SEO rich articles
because you learned that as a journalist
writing for prints is different than
writing for online and then we learned
that we were hit by the medic update
which is your sites that fall under your
money your life and our SEO editor was
like you just need to follow what the
acronym is eat which is expertise
authority Authority Tivnan and
trustworthiness but a lot of those sites
like I don't know if you're familiar
with self hacked Joe Cohen
that's an amazing site if you're a bio
hacker which I consider myself a bio
hacker that the minutiae the details
whether you want to learn about combo or
NAC and then basically he was saying I
am following that acronym I am showing
expertise expertise authoritative nough
sand trustworthiness so here is Google
saying well yeah you just need to follow
this and you'll regain in your
and then speaking to someone like Zach
who's confirming and going No they have
black lists they're pushing information
down what [ __ ] chance do you what
unless we truth seekers now unite and so
I've told this to Zach that I think
having gone through this technical
fascism in regards to CBD that I've kind
of been jaded because I was feeling like
I was putting on armor every day having
to battle finding a processor or getting
robbed or or now losing all the traffic
and now I feel like there's a movement
that's creating that that's forming
where we're standing to for freedom of
speech and and in health freedom and
sovereignty sovereignty hello yeah that
that this um this process of me figuring
out what is most optimal for me to bring
my gifts into the world requires me to
have an amount of free will and amount
of trusted sources that can help me
reflect on Who I am and what my purpose
is and how I can eat well and get good
have good health and have good sources
of information for me to figure out how
to bring my gift to the world and if any
of that gets distorted along the way
which it seems like it has since the
tribal days up until now been distorted
towards self dealing away from inclusive
stake holding then now it makes it so
that people fall into the economic
machinery they fall into less
sovereignty they fall into more
manipulations of their free will and
what is the hidden agenda behind this
what does what do people want to get out
of misinformation control control what
are you saying Kalyn I mean it's it's
very like again Barnard says to not
focus on the shadows on the wall yeah
yeah what are the roots not the symptoms
and now were were specifically it's very
confusing
like even even let's I give an example I
had read a story about systemic
pesticides that was very well-written
that I questioned ten years
my own research and then I was like who
is this guy John in teen and then
realized that he's a big AG apologist
that he's hired by Monsanto with a
scientific mind to spread this
disinformation so now the disinformation
there's no shortage of it and people are
confused and again the zombies are here
the future is now I think I can give
people an also a relatable example of
this yeah so this is like whoever has
the deepest pockets in whatever thing
that they're bringing to the world
whatever product or service to bring to
the world they have incentive to spread
misinformation about all of the other
up-and-coming potentials that are better
than they are because then they
themselves can can fund their own
pockets it's a monopoly mentality of
that I want to propagate my own outcome
I want to be an organism that can do
something that prevents the other
organisms from trying to get the
resources that I'm getting and so versus
you know ideally in a you know I can
envision a future where instead it's
something along the lines of I see
myself or this organization as its own
creative permutation and all these other
other creative permutations are
happening how can we do things like be
able to share breasts best practices
across these organizations and help
actually do our goal which is to provide
more truth and to provide more health
and to provide more food and more people
bringing their gifts fully into the
world there's a new economy there's a
new world a new paradigm that's moving
forward and being a part of that is is
is it's without question this most
important thing is being designers of
the architecture of the new world one is
based on scarcity one is based on
abundance but I guess that's a I brought
up my sister and I don't know if you
have siblings but it's like how do you
teach someone to be a truth seeker what
is it like from a very young age that
I've been like maybe a journalist by
design of asking questions of wanting to
reach you know even like as a kid
picking up rocks and wanting to look at
the ants underneath and the hidden oral
the invisible world we don't give
credence to the invisible world
I mean I'm I've been dealing with mold
toxicity and healing from that that's
invisible and no case no judges or
attorneys want to take it on because of
this arrogance of like you need needs to
be so visual and so the the invisible
world is also let's say the resonance of
the heart that you can't is there you
can measure it but it's not tangible so
I don't know how you teach someone
spirituality or that there's something
greater that magic exists i I don't I
don't know you have feelings of non
separation can help people feelings of
interconnectedness which is one
meditation and psychedelics yeah
community child from a child's
perspective into the world is for them
to actually be rooted in that
interconnectedness and not in rooted in
separation I was yeah and I would also
add not having a victim mentality
because today it seems like we're
awarding victimless victimhood and it's
like if I shared like if I'm sharing
that I've been victimized by the system
which I have doesn't mean that I am a
victim just because I'm sharing it
because I'm not rolling over and saying
woe is me I'm saying okay let how can we
solve this what's the solution how can
we hack this how can you think outside
of the box and not give up because a lot
of people said why you still selling CBD
because I'm helping people because CBD
is amazing
because I'm doing it properly because
it's legal I'm not doing anything wrong
why am I not able to be abundant and
help people at the same time
so this this suppression right now I
mean again to reference Bernard that if
we're looking at like cattle and how we
manipulate cattle like to think that
maybe the elite are manipulating us and
seeing you know let's get them sick
along the way and make money off of them
there's too many of them and that these
these elites that that's what you know
very small portion of people are
controlling most of the resources this
is fact
yeah fifty percent of all new wealth
generated goes to the one percent and
also to think that if someone is [ __ ]
thinking about me and other divine
beings as [ __ ] cattle it's time to
[ __ ] find them and we are finding
them yeah yeah exactly
it's coming it's becoming more and more
transparent you can't you can't hide if
you're spiritually awakened or not it's
me you can't hide it anymore people are
finding it sniffing it I think it's it's
like the gig the jig's up dude you're
naked Emperor we can see you how are we
still continuing this farce and so
they're kind of grasping for straws
trying to control us and also Big Pharma
realizes how many billions of dollars
that people are moving away from
conventional ways of healing yep and
that we have the resources to heal but
you have to have that belief first and
not just think just because you're
wearing a lab coat that you have the
answers yeah or the idea that like how
arrogant I'm not a doctor but I sure
know more than lots of doctors because I
believe in nutrition and if I've been I
am I'm just here to say I'm walking my
talk this is what I'm striving for
I've been how many doctors say let food
be thy medicine yeah I don't think I
don't think I really rarely rarely ever
hear a doctor say something yeah yeah
and that's some of the oldest poem
yes dollar Cities and I say food is thy
medicine or food is thy folk today
and how about do no harm do no harm
there's been hella harm in Western
medicine and that goes you know there's
great investigative reporters I've
certainly covered being a pawn that's
another way to put it yeah am I am I in
my upon in someone else's chess game
that's a great way and a lot of us are
being it uses Ponton if you see yourself
engaging in vitriol and wasting your
energy on social media to get a dopamine
hit it's like this is like a waste of
energy this is distraction distraction
distraction what really matters and that
goes back to having a purpose and
wanting it's like personally I rather
just download information all all day
long and like just connect the dots and
see the patterns rather than engage in
like BS or go drink booze which I don't
of course drink I have a couple
questions to ask on the way out what do
you think about this statement ok
humanity is a biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence humanity is a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence does that mean that we are
here to
propagate and focus on technology that
we're heading towards a virtual world
that we're heading towards a simulation
or er in a simulation how are you
defining that yes yes stuff like that
for sure
well I've I've it's I found myself
feeling like I'm already caught in a
simulation that I see sometimes little
moments of glitches or like within again
the realm of CBD like I call 2017 the
year of playing whack-a-mole it's a wake
waking up Oh $13,000 is gone
oh I'm banned for life of PayPal Oh like
the latest one was I was working with a
company called behalf which is out of
it's a factoring company it's out of
Israel and waking up they had just
increased my our credit line from 8,000
to 10,000 we always paid on time we had
done it many times over and then wake up
your gauntly orb and you're suspended
and then looking in and going on Sequoia
Capital has invested in them Sequoia has
so anyone who has dealings it's just
very insidious and you have to do deep
digging but it's it's permeating way
beyond Google I mean Google is just like
the fact that you can say Google is a
drug company now anyway that my point
was of seeing glitches in them in the
simulation and having had let's say a
DMT trip where I woke up and it was kind
of like in the matrix feeling like I'm
in Google it was actually with Bernard
mm-hmm and there was a woman at the edge
of the of the cot I guess and and she
kind of like gave me a look like ah
we've have one that's woken up and I
remember like looking around the corner
to kind of like Blade Runner trying to
see where I am but still had one foot in
in the third plane
it's very short though and then there
was a track and at that moment it's a
it's a well known track I just heard
wake up wake up it was very symbolic and
then I came back but then in that
experience realizing there's so much
more and of course if you implant
medicine you you realize yeah there's so
much more this physical world is is
beautiful but the limitations of not
being able to like see animism or see or
you know you can tap into the feelings
of these interconnected states and
that's that's not tangible like you know
that cup is like you can make magic
magic exists I see magic all the time i
you know and i think on the in the other
way there's also evil spells that are
being cast potentially the ones that
you're talking about techno fascism the
pressure on the show have you seen the
movie Midnight Express mainland Express
no midnight excellent Midnight Express
it's it's it's about gentleman it's a
real story who who tries to smuggle her
sheesh from Turkey back into the country
and then gets thirty years but I
reference that because there's a gosh
yeah yeah yeah it's not it was not a fun
scene but there's a scene where they
were going around the wheel there Muslim
and one of the guy goes join us brother
and he's going the opposite way and then
he says to him
oh you don't realize that you're you're
a bad machine and that you've been put
here so the the idea is like just the
analogy I'm using is that he he says I'm
the machine maker and he ends up
escaping but realizing the doesn't want
to be just part of a machine part of a
cog in a wheel want to be sovereign and
awake and there's so much more and there
is magic out there yeah if you decide
you want to explore that yes yes this
for every child to have the opportunity
to explore that
that spirit that interconnectedness that
belonging and not just the forces of the
economic machinery pressing against and
the visa brought me a lot of magic they
they've reminded I've had so many
electrical experiences with honeybees
even how we found Ellen Page was was
magical and being in nature reminds you
of magic yeah yeah
does it reminds you of
interconnectedness um last question that
uh we like asking our guests what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in
creation the most beautiful thing in
creation give me a moment because
there's a lot of beautiful things of
course do you mean like in nature what
is the most beautiful thing in creation
well to me it's just nature being in
nature just a sense of other creatures
and and like the jungle I don't know
because the jungle can spit you out
having lived in Costa Rica and just
having so much reverence and I just say
thank you mother nature for not spitting
me out of the jungle because it's not
easy being there and then you really
realize like the with the life and death
and how interconnected it is yeah so
nature in the sense of like when you're
in Costa Rica you see a different insect
or creature every single day mm-hmm and
you realize that you're so you're you're
just part of something so much bigger
I'd also say like the the stars and the
galaxies yeah just yeah if when you can
see the sky when you can actually see
all the stars and just really get a
sense of wonderment which maybe has been
suppressed specifically when are living
in these cement jungles or worse living
our life looking at a screen yes
living in cement Joe goes looking at
screens takes us away from being able to
see the non light polluted
the Stars and from the
interconnectedness of the jungles inside
those oh my gosh so much there yeah
thank you so much for coming on our show
we're so grateful thank you for coming
on the program again yeah this has been
super enlightening really appreciate you
thank you for all your work yeah and I
really hope that the things that we
talked about in the episode that the
that can be hopefully shared more around
around the world we we highly request
you guys check check out the links in
the bio blow to Miriam's Twitter profile
also her feature in the POC times also
honey colony comm check out all of those
links thank you and please I would say
to us being shadow band to please follow
me on Twitter yeah go and follow her on
Twitter you actually write that that you
know being shadow band she needs that's
those these are her last means of being
able to stay in the free speech world
yeah
free speech world and I want to thank
you also because when I do interviews
it's not very common to bring the
spirituality to it or people think it's
like woo and I tell people I'm only one
part woo because I'm very grounded
person and and looked to science but
that don't deny ya the spirituality and
and we do both that's why it helps when
you've one foot in science and one in
spirit and there's just yep that's what
that's what gets you to the next world
yeah I agree there's a magazine called
actually science and spirit that I've
written for ya all for that so check out
the links in the Bible everyone also
support the conversations these cut
these points that we had today on the
show support them share them around the
world get talking more about the
subjects what is the big force that's
behind what's happening and stay
vigilant stay critical thinking about
everything that's happening and
world for suresies yes yes thank you or
Shapira for the co-production greatly
appreciated thank you and also support
the artists entrepreneurs leaders the
spiritual elders around the world do you
believe and support them and help them
grow you can find all of our links in
our bio below help us join us go and
build the future everyone manifest that
new world we love you very much and
we'll see you soon
aho